that was so beautiful thank you for that
all right let's move on now to the great
toy drive it has taken or has taken over
the tobin auto group the sponsors of
this next segment i stopped by one of
their dealerships to see how they're
helping us make a difference this
holiday season
the great toy drive is underway
partnered with of course channel 8 and
tobin auto group hiring thank you for
joining us thank you so of course we're
talking about toys for the community so
what was your favorite toy growing up
rocky i don't know if you remember the
soccer ball folks but me and my sister
oh man i remember those
so much fun so much that's what toys
create great memories for kids so let's
talk about what we're doing for the kids
in our community okay so what we're
doing is uh we're partnering up with
channel a and the shade tree which is an
organization that helps battered kids
and better women so we're just so
grateful to be a part of this and to be
able to provide joy for these kids um on
christmas that's what it's all about and
we have these boxes at all of your
locations here at the valley auto mall
so what can people bring in what kind of
toys uh any unopened toys brand new
unopened toys
dolls balls like anything you guys could
think of anything that's going to bring
joy to these kids
so that's that's what you guys could
bring that's what it's all about that's
why chop the owner of tobin auto group
brought this to the dealership right yes
and um i was having a conversation with
top the other day and
man we are so blessed to be able to like
celebrate christmas all year round with
our customers they come in they have a
great time and they they just light up
like a christmas tree when they get a
new car so we're so happy to do the same
thing for the kids in need oh man
speaking of lighting up like a christmas
tree on the adult end yeah and they come
and get a new car
did you see the one behind you this is a
fully custom
yes yes you are all black everything
exactly so tell us about this one this
is so cool
yeah that one's on sale that one's uh
fully custom the guy this is actually
paint it looks like stickers but they
painted the entire car and the guy did a
great job so we're excited to have it on
our showroom this is so cool and of
course we are at tobin kia so what kind
of cars does kia provide for the
community
yeah he has a little mix of everything
they have like the the fun sporty cars
they also have the the family uh suvs
and sedans so they have a little mix of
everything okay so when you're coming
down to look at the cars you guys make
sure you bring your unwrapped brand new
toys for the kids at the shade tree they
need it the most they do and we're so
happy to give back to our community
thank you thank you rocky
[Music]
our great toy drive continues through
next week with the help of tobin auto
group and telus international you can
drop off a new unwrapped toy or even a
gift card at any of the dealerships on
your screen right now the donations will
benefit the shade tree organization
kendall